if you were to look at the american
nation the american empire
and the trajectories looking into the
future
given these measures
what is the trajectory that leads to the
collapse of the american empire based on
these measures what are the concerning
indicators and if
um if those break down further what does
that look like
well
all of those indicators
are
concerning maybe
except for one which is technology
the technology niche
although
even in that area the united states is
improving at a slower rate than is china
for various advantages that they have
there they put out about eight times as
many computer engineers they have free
data and so on
but if you look at them
so the financial is a is a concern
the
internal order disorder is a concern
then if you look at education levels
the united states
is in many way is is losing its
educational advantage
if you were to look at compare it with
china
if you take general public education in
the united states it's deteriorated uh
tremendously even in comparison to
developed countries their scores pisa
scores and so on and it's you know
something like 38th in the world or
something and that was a big plunge
average public education if you look at
the best universities in the world the
united states is unique in having the
best universities in the world so there
are these privileged spots
um that are you know excellent
uniquely excellent so when you look at
the comparison education in china
is improving rapidly
and it and the quantity
is a quantity of educated people in the
areas that they're moving in are is is
greater and the resources that they're
putting behind it is greater and so you
see the results are greater
um but
it's sort of along the lines that i'm
i'm dealing with if you were to follow
through
in terms of um
actual productions i i think you you
know in terms of technologies
um there are some areas that the united
states is in a lead at the moment
there's some areas that china's in a
lead but china is great gaining
very quickly